[singing]
Genay Kirkpatrick:
I just want to give a warm welcome to the class of 2015. We're really excited that you
guys are here, and I hope this is a good start to what is going to be a great Princeton career.
Gregory Groves:
... a great welcoming environment. Like, the first week you're here, just meet all these
smiling faces welcoming you here into the community.
Suzannah Beiner:
Hi, my name is Suzannah Beiner. I'm class of 2015, very glad to be here from Sebring, Fla.
Go Tigers!
[singing, drumming]
Matthew Cramer:
I remember when I was a freshman, it was the first time I stepped back and thought,
"Wow, this is really amazing."
Shirley M. Tilghman:
Over the next four years, your Princeton education will stretch your minds in ways that you can
only begin to imagine now. Preparing you to be informed and effective citizens of this
Shirley M. Tilghman:
and all countries -- citizens who are able to draw understanding from and discern the
most fruitful path amid the immense sea of facts surrounding them. I am looking forward
Shirley M. Tilghman:
to getting to know each of you and to cheering you on inside and outside the classroom as
you chart your course through this great University. I hope you will leave our campus saying,
Shirley M. Tilghman:
as generations of students before you have said, "This place changed my life."
Suzannah Beiner:
President Tilghman's opening address really put my four years in perspective. College is about
new experiences and Princeton really encourages students to try new things. I'm going to push the
Suzannah Beiner:
boundaries and explore new possibilities and be an even better person than when I got here.
[music, drumming]
Alec Slatkey:
We're here, as we are every year, to welcome the freshmen to Princeton as they walk through the gates.
[singing]
Rachael DeLue:
Tonight's talk was about a very large question, which is, "How do we represent history?"
And it was inspired, of course, by the fact that today is the tenth anniversary of Sept. 11.
Rachael DeLue:
One of the great pleasures of teaching at Princeton, of being a professor at Princeton,
is that I get to figure things out in collaboration with students such as yourselves. It's meant
Rachael DeLue:
to frame the students' experience at Princeton, which is about asking questions. History matters,
but the manner in which we describe history matters just as much. We have a historical
Rachael DeLue:
responsibility but also an ethical responsibility to tell the story of our past completely and
fully and from multiple points of view. Doing that will help us make decisions for the greater good.
Clayton Raithel:
And now, as per Princeton tradition, we'd like to invite all of the a cappella groups
that sang with us tonight back on stage for the singing of "Old Nassau."
[singing]
Clayton Raithel:
Thank you. Thank you very much, guys. Enjoy the rest of your evening and your time here at Princeton.